all right guys bang-bang I've got Jack
here with me thanks for taking the time
to do this yeah thank you for sure so
for those that don't know you you have
lived many different lives based on your
background maybe kind of just give us a
an overview where you grew up and then
how do you get into the military and
civil walk you did there yeah sure I
grew up in suburban New York a town you
know started off it's called North
Tarrytown and we changed our names in
the 1990s to Sleepy Hollow I graduated
from North Salem High School and joined
the army at 19 and went into you know
infantry basic training and then the
Ranger indoctrination program and served
in 3rd Ranger Battalion in the Army and
deployed to Afghanistan and Iraq and
from there I went over to Special Forces
and I served in 5th Special Forces Group
deployed back to Iraq and then I got out
of the Army in 2010 went to college
majored in political science at Columbia
graduated in 2014 and have basically
worked in journalism and media ever
since then you know really heavily
covering national security particularly
the Special Operations community the
intelligence community claimed ésta in
covert operations those are kind of the
things that I normally cover got it and
so when you're in the Ranger Battalion
and you're getting deployed maybe talk a
little bit just about the work you guys
are doing there and then how that
differed from once you'd gone through
all the Special Forces training and you
win back what was the difference in
terms of the the types of missions in
the work you guys were doing sure yeah
so the the differences between Special
Forces and range of regimen are pretty
stark the two units have different
missions Rangers will typically work in
platoon sized elements maybe even up the
company or battalion sized elements
depending on you know the scope of the
mission
Special Forces operates in 12 man teams
called OTAs operational detachment alpha
and their Special Forces operates in a
more decentralized environment you know
there's no one really telling you how to
do your job there just isn't time for
and you're all NCOs on a special-forces
team you're all sergeants so you're
really expected to know your job and to
just do it without being I mean
literally there's nobody and there's no
time to hold your hand and micromanage
what you're doing particularly on
deployment so when I was with Ranger
Battalion we were part of the Joint
Special Operations task force in Iraq we
were actioning targets hitting multiple
targets during every 24-hour period
they're you know considered time
sensitive targets so we're just going
out again and again and again the churn
was very quickly in Special Forces I was
working as a senior adviser to a Iraqi
SWAT team about a hundred people so I
was almost kind of like the company
commander really for them and I trained
them with some of my other teammates on
the ODA we trained them every day and
then when operations came to us we would
be you know the senior tactical advisors
taking them out on missions got it and
so as you're doing this
how much kind of understanding do you
have both about what's going on on a
much larger scale right so I was in the
military through the National Guard
deployed to Iraq and for us where there
was no kind of Special Operations
training nor mission set we basically
knew hey here's our mission today but
didn't have great insight into like how
we fit into a much larger battle plan
that kind of leadership would it would
have foresight into we were much more
just here's your mission go execute that
mission come back for you guys did you
have more insight into kind of the
broader plan and kind of the you know
the the genius behind the madness if you
will or was it very much kind of here's
your target here's your mission go
execute come back I mean I think we had
a very cursory understanding of what the
larger strategic picture was you know
similar to what you mentioned I think
that there was a notion you know when I
was in Ranger Battalion doing those
types of missions that we were trying to
degrade defeat and destroy what we
called al-qaeda in Iraq so we're trying
to put them on their heels put them on
their ass and kind of short-circuit the
insurgency in Special Forces
there's 2009
by the time I was there with SF so the
mission was more about getting the Iraqi
military to stand up on their own two
feet to build you know to some extent
building capacity in the Iraqi
government so that the American forces
can withdraw I mean a policy decision
had already been made that we were gonna
pull out of the country so that was
about as much as I could tell you on the
you know big strategic level for the
most part it is you know hey this is
your little part of the world this is
your mission and you know you go execute
it as best you can for sure and what was
the impetus for you to go from the
ranger battalion to want to go on the
Special Forces side I know some guys get
kind of recruited and pulled up some say
you know raise their hand and say I'd
like to volunteer to go do this where
did you fall on that and understanding
that you'd already been deployed before
- didn't want to go through the Special
Forces training a lot of people outside
the military be like that's crazy but
kind of talked through a little bit of
the logic there well I think there were
a couple things that played into it for
me personally you know growing up and
Ranger Battalion is great I think it is
absolutely the best place in the army
for a young soldier to go but it's also
not necessarily the place that you want
to spend your entire career it's very
regimented it's very disciplined for
good reason but you as you look at it
you think you know do I really want to
spend the next you know eight years the
next 12 years however much longer I'm in
the army do I want to spend it yelling
at privates because they're wearing the
wrong color socks like is that my thing
and also you know the mission its kind
of more of the same I mean I think I was
only in range over time for what like
three years and I think we seized Lawson
airfield on Fort Benning like 12 times I
mean at a certain point you're like okay
like I'm ready for something new and
Special Forces offered that so and I
also have met a lot of SF guys at other
places during my army career like it
when I went to Ranger School I'm
shooting in the whole army competition
things like that I cross paths with
Special Forces NCOs and got to pick
their brains a little bit about their
job and what they do so it was um I'm
happy with it and what I did I mean I
thought it was a good choice for me
yeah and they talked a little bit about
the Special Forces training
I would tell people if they want to
understand it really indefinitely to go
read the book masters in chaos seems to
be one of the the better written books
on the topic but just kind of what was
your experience like going through that
while the United States is at war you
know two different countries
yeah it is interesting and that all of
your NCOs all of your instructors are
combat veterans they're all coming out
of theater and now they're trying to get
you ready get the next generation of
guys ready to go into it it was a it was
interesting I you know I went through
Special Forces assessment selection in
winter of 2005 it was a ball buster
you know I won't lie to you I came right
off my deployment in Iraq with Ranger
Battalion came back and did a training
cycle with Ranger Battalion and then
went right into Special Forces selection
like literally the next day I was on a
plane got there so by that time I
finished sfas I was mentally and
physically exhausted like I won't be su
about that like I was I was just done
buddy
but I got selected and then you start
the Special Forces qualification course
that includes you know you small unit
tactics training you go to the survival
escape resistance Innovation course you
get your language training in my case
was Arabic you go to your your MOS your
military occupational job training for
Special Forces in my case I was a weapon
sergeant so that was a pretty cool
course and and then the cumulative
exercise at the end of it it's called
Robin sage and it puts you into a
simulated unconventional warfare
scenario and now it takes place in
literally in communities in North
Carolina were you integrate with a local
population and you meet them and work
with them and you know it ranges from
you know you could end up taking little
boy scouts out on training missions
countin training combat missions in
Robin sage with Boy Scouts too you know
I was in people's houses drinking red
wine with them you know trying to make
em trying to rub shoulders like these
guys are like partisan forces I went to
church with somebody else and we did a
little like handshake where he had to he
handed off like
secret note to me with the intel on it
like in the middle of a church service
but it's a really fun exercise very
useful exercise also in introducing you
know green beret students to what their
job is supposed to be yeah and then as
you deployed with this fifth group did
you know that you know hey I'm gonna
spend another one or two years doing
this and then eventually I'm gonna go
ahead and transition out go to school
and have some master plan or basically
just take each year kind of one by one
no I I did kind of take each year one by
one as it came I did have some idea in
my mind I would have you know like to
have stayed in for a career and I'm the
type of person like I'm just a bad job
satisfaction I didn't care about
careerism I don't care if I I don't need
to be the sergeant major of the army I
don't care um you know if I got to be
the senior eighteen Bravo on an Oda for
twelve years and then you know finish
the last couple years it's like the
Intel NCO on the team that would been
fine for me but I mean I just saw it
just the mind crushing soul-crushing
bureaucracy of the army and what was
going on in that unit and it just gets
to the point where it's like man why am
I here like why am I even why am I doing
this if all the initiative has already
been taken out of your hands if all the
decisions have been made you don't have
any ability to plan things or to make
things better in the unit because you
know your higher headquarters this isn't
garrison that your higher headquarters
is you know engaging in that hand
holding and that micromanaging it's like
what am I doing here you know like
someone told me at one point in the unit
he was like you know if you treat a boy
like a man yes the man up but if you
treat a man like a boy he's gonna
default to that so that was kind of my
experience there and what led to me you
know ultimately tweak in the Army in
2010 yeah that's a great quote that
couldn't be more true in terms of how
you treat people it's basically how they
end up acting when you were on
deployment with Special Forces teams any
like memorable moments outside of kind
of the combat and the things that people
really focus on I think a lot of people
don't understand kind of the camaraderie
and the like nah
mission type environment and how that's
just very different than what they
probably expect you know it's funny you
ask that because just yesterday my
daughter was asking me something about
like medical issues or or like do I know
she's asking if I go to the doctor do I
have to get a shot and I was like oh let
me tell you about when we learned while
our medic told us taught us how to give
shots in the army on our Special Forces
team and like one by one we each take
turns putting on the rubber gloves and
your buddy would drop trou and you'd
grab a big handful of his ass in one
fist and then take the shot the
vaccination needle and our medics like
yeah you just throw it like a dart like
you're playing darts you throw it into a
dartboard but right into an ass cheek
give them the shot and pull it out and
put it in the sharps container so you're
you know that's probably not something
that people do on their normal everyday
job grabbing their buddy's ass and
sticking a needle in it but you know hey
it's the army the reason why I'm
laughing is because a lot of these
things are they're life-saving measures
right you know all the different
training organizations and kind of
courses they put you through but when
you're in the military there's
definitely a different view of it and
it's almost like you got a joke around
doing it because it's so ridiculous what
you do understand that long term like
hey it's probably good that they're
training us on all this stuff yeah no
absolutely absolutely in the end the
medics we have the best trained medics
in the world without question and
they're very good about kind of spread
that knowledge around and teaching you
as much as they possibly can because you
know on the battlefield there aren't
enough medics to go around there never
are
so each soldier has to be a first
responder it has to be you know have
combat lifesaver skills so they really
you know do a lot of cross-training with
you for sure and so when you decided to
go ahead and leave the military what was
the plan did you know hey I'm gonna go
to school or kind of how did you end up
at Columbia oh geez I mean yeah I did
not have a real solid plan I did plan on
going to college I started looking at
colleges was actually looking at using
trying to use my GI Bill to go to school
in London that was kind of my plan but
the the problem with that as great as
the post 9/11 GI Bill is one limitation
it has
if you go to school overseas the bah
they pay you the housing allowance is
based on a u.s. national housing average
so you'd be getting paid like 500 bucks
living in London like that's just not
gonna work so went to school of the
United States
I started often my first year in mercy
and Dobbs Ferry and then I transferred
to Columbia in Manhattan and you know
initially I was a business major
international business major then when I
transferred I think I was a history
major and then and then toss that aside
now I ended up going to political
science for sure and so as you've kind
of gone from you know a teenager to a
ranger Special Forces to then having a
grant or a college degree from Columbia
through all of that like what was kind
of the the North Star for you right I'm
always interested in this idea of most
people I talk to they actually don't
have one right it's kind of that they're
figuring it out as they go and then
eventually they like find something and
they go all in on it you've spent the
last call it six years or so around
media and journalism and and kind of all
of this international relations
political science special forces stuff
and it seems like like you kind of found
that thing now but did you have that
before you graduated did you have
interest in media or is that just
something that kind of naturally you
progressed into it's something that I
naturally progressed into it wasn't a
plan or anything like that it was just a
series of things that sort of happened
and then you know finding what I what I
enjoy doing and if you think about it
I've kind of kept a foot in the same
thing all along I mean I wanted to be in
the army since I was a little kid I
joined the army and I did that and then
since leaving I've covered the military
and I've been to Syria a couple times as
a journalist I've been to Iraq a couple
times as a journalist I've been to South
Korea I've been to the Philippines were
in that capacity and I cover these
issues you know journalistically all the
time so I've kind of always kept a hand
in it and I mean if there's any North
Star I think it's just my my own
curiosity and wanting to know how things
work
you know to find the secrets what are
the what are the secrets that our
government is keeping behind the curtain
and trying to uncover those and discover
those things and beyond that you know
reporting what's true and what's
accurate and you know cutting through
that because I think there's just this
very fascinating place where there is
you know what is true and there's what
you're allowed to say and those things
can be two different things at the same
time and when that situation occurs I
think it's very interesting and I think
that's a that's a fun place to work as a
journalist for sure and so when you go
back to I'll call them combat zones not
all of them are actually designated that
way but the places like Syria Iraq and
and just kind of have higher levels of
danger how is it different as a
journalist versus when you're carrying a
gun
you know Special Forces or a ranger like
that there's different missions set that
you're there to do or job to do but you
also have different equipment like once
the camera one's a gun yeah how did you
kind of think through that or level set
that mentally well it's a hell of a lot
more dangerous for starters you know
like I was saying before that we have
the best trained medics in the world
when it you know when you're in Special
Forces or Rangers well when you're a
journalist you don't have a medic stand
of mine but you know to help you if you
get shot you don't have air strikes on
call if you need them you're not armed I
you know you just do not have you don't
have the logistics you know and it's
very invigorating it almost intoxicating
in some ways that you get to find your
own missions and and find your own
stories and you negotiate safe passage
through closed international borders and
you're doing these things that the army
would never ever have let me do I was
able to go places and talk to people and
do things that the army would freak out
over so you have this freedom and this
self initiative that's Masonic self
reliance on yourself but you have to
make all these things happen because
nobody's going to do it for you as a you
know as a freelancer as an independent
journalist you know nobody's looking
over your shoulder no one's telling you
to go left go right it's all on you but
you know it's also exhausting and
difficult and
and it is quite dangerous so I mean as
far as my approach I'd say you know two
of the people who I guess inspired me
from a journalistic perspective is
Robert Young Pelton and Jim Morris
the latter being a journalist for
Soldier of Fortune magazine who served
as a green beret in Vietnam and Robert
Young Pelton was a journal he is a
journalist who you know he was all about
kind of just like embedding with local
rebel forces and just going into places
like Chechnya going into places like
Somalia kind of fearlessly
but without you know he was never asking
anyone for a Hall Pass you know was it
was the impression I got I really
admired that and you know I think he
wrote a book called come back alive that
I read it when I was a very young
soldier that kind of I think trickled
off and rubbed off on me in a lot of
ways got it and so any situations where
a sure there's a journalist some of the
Special Forces training and things like
that end up becoming an asset to you
obviously just naturally I'm sure
staying out of danger not going places
that you shouldn't go you know some of
that type of stuff that's more
intangible but in any kind of exact
situations you remember being like wow
I'm really glad that now that I'm here
as a journalist I have that Special
Forces training 100% I mean all the time
you know I mean on that that background
to inform my reporting and you know when
I was in bat and you know I was in a
battle with the Peshmerga one time and I
mean I just had a much better
understanding of the battlefield and
what was going on there then I think
maybe other people would have had when I
meet soldiers anywhere you're able to
you know I'm able to speak the same
language that they are and maybe build a
little bit of a rapport that they might
not have with somebody who is you know
say you know a journalism major or
something like that so it's yes I mean
on that experience tremendously I think
yeah it helps keep me alive and it helps
you know inform how I write stories
going
frankly yeah and one of the reasons why
I'd reach out student wanted to do this
conversation was I saw that you were one
of the first if not the first to
recently talk about the domestic
deployment of the 82nd airborne right
and it just kind of caught me off guard
of wait a second here's a guy who comes
from the Special Forces in Ranger world
so he has an understanding of how the
military works that most don't have to
he has got early access or first access
to a story that is pretty big deal for a
whole bunch of reasons we get into and
then three was like the mainstream media
either hadn't picked it up yet didn't
understand the gravity of the situation
or whatever and so it to me just like
really highlight of like this is kind of
the future of a lot of reporting right
is more of the independence being able
to leverage their personal experiences
their personal networks and access to
information to surface as you said
earlier like the truth right and and
that's so powerful today so maybe let's
start with just like talk us through
kind of that story and kind of how you
came across it and why you thought it
was important enough to kind of bring it
to light on Twitter and elsewhere yeah
sure you know they absolutely with all
the the recent civil unrest going on in
the United States and we had a protest
movement a peaceful protest movement and
unfortunately some rioters and some
other violent aspects you know trying to
hijack that movement and you know a
heavy police presence getting deployed
the National Guard being deployed and
these are all things that are sort of to
be expected right and for a governor to
deploy the National Guard it's perfectly
lawful and evil and normal there's
nothing irregular about that but then
when I had a source reach out to me and
say that the 82nd Airborne Division's
IRF their immediate response force had
been told to pack their bags and get
ready to leave this was back on Saturday
so two Saturdays ago now that they had
been you know as at least on a self
initiative they've been too alerted and
told to be ready to go they received the
actual alert a few days later on Monday
they were out doing E I be Wayne's
expert infantryman
so they're on Fort Bragg on their base
doing normal infantry training and they
get the word that they are being
deployed this is it there they have a
CONUS domestic deployment and MP cars
pulled up blocked off the roads so that
they could get right to their station
right to their brigade dry out all of
their gear throw it on pallets pack it
all do whatever they had to do and then
get down to Pope Air Force Base and they
were prepped there and in the early
morning hours it would have been Tuesday
early Tuesday they flew on helicopters
huge 60 helicopters Blackhawks and c-17
transport how its transport aircraft and
flew to Joint Base Andrews in the
National Capital Region so as I was I
first learned about this when the
initial alert happened on Saturday I
reported it then when they actually
deployed that Tuesday early Tuesday
morning I reported on that and it was
kind of shocking that yeah the the rest
of the press did not pick up on this
story until way later and I could
speculate on why that is but at the end
of the day you had what is now a very
irregular deployment happening
you have active-duty paratroopers being
deployed ostensibly
I mean for riot control measures on US
soil now the 82nd airborne has been
deployed in this sort of capacity in the
past back in like the 1970s maybe there
was one in the 1980s but it's sending
paratroopers after you know protesters
or rioters in American cities it's not
something that happens every day in
order to do it
president Trump probably would have had
to evoke the 1807 insurrection act which
is essentially a loophole to Posse
Comitatus that says in times where there
is rebellion and insurrection where
people are having their constitutional
rights violated but the states cannot or
will not protect those people's rights
then the federal government can deploy
active-duty soldiers to try to mitigate
that so in a lot of ways we walked right
out
to the brink last week we walked right
up to that line up to that precipice you
know the United States military has
amazing support from the American public
and my poll after poll like America
loves the military they love the troops
but the day that we have active-duty
soldiers in the streets
god forbid killing people because an
altercation erupts between protesters or
rioters and you can do you just imagined
the Wikipedia page on that one in 2030
saying you know general Milley presided
over the 82nd Airborne Division's
deployment to Washington DC during the
2020 riots where they opened fire on
peaceful civil rights demonstrators what
is that something like that and I mean
thank God that didn't happen but we came
really close to it this last week yeah
and I think part of my understanding of
this right is there's kind of multiple
stages of importance so one is just like
you described the deployment of active
duty military a lot of people don't
realize the National Guard is not active
duty military it's very much run by the
state governors and so it has kind of a
different kind of objective and a
different organizational structure yes
they have a uniform that looks pretty
similar yes they've got guns like all
that kind of stuff but it but it is
different to your point just being
deployed is a big step but to is that
deployment has a connotation that comes
with it of much more kind of serious
clampdown right from the federal
government and I think you and I
probably both see a situation where like
soldiers are Americans first and they
are very much there to kind of protect
and serve and want to do the right
things but they also are trained very
differently than the police right and so
it's kind of your point maybe kind of
elaborate on that a little bit of just
like you have probably some of the best
training in the world coming from that
it's very different than the six you
know six week to six month kind of
police training program like how do you
think about that difference yeah I would
point out also I don't have any
critique of the 82nd Airborne Division I
mean these are good soldiers and the
immediate response force the IRF is you
know it's advertised as America's nine
nine one one call right the president
called him up and immediately deploy
them they did on New Year's Eve as
tensions form out mounting with Iran
they deployed to Iraq so I mean these
guys did their job and they are
effective and IRF is effective and it
can function in times of emergency when
America needs paratroopers you know on
target these guys can do it the problem
in this case is that the 82nd airport
isn't trained or equipped for riot
control it's not their job they're
paratroopers they're airborne
infantrymen I mean think about the guys
who jumped into Normandy right that's
their bread and butter that's what they
do these guys maneuver and close with
and destroy the enemy I you know as
maybe some NCOs might say they you know
kill people and break things that's
their job it's the army this is what
they do
so deploying those same soldiers for a
domestic disturbance to do some sort of
riot control is very concerning because
the you know you have soldiers who are
wired up they're looking to fight this
is what they do and you know once one of
them gets hit with a brick you don't
know what's gonna you don't really know
how quickly that's gonna escalate and
what are the the force control measures
what are that escalation measures what
are the Aquos roee going to look like
and I can tell you and I haven't talked
about this or written about this
anywhere else
but when they deployed the IRF that it
was specifically it was the medium
response battalion one of the immediate
response force so i rb1 deployed Joint
Base Andrews they get there then they
get moved to a gymnasium at Fort Belvoir
and they are sitting on cots and you had
82nd airborne paratroopers sitting
around discussing with one another the
legalities of what they're being asked
to do and they're having conversations
about the US Constitution and whether or
not this is right or wrong and I don't
fault them for that at all but I don't
think they ever should have been put in
that situation in the first place you
so this is the meat of the conversation
right in my opinion which is let's first
talk about ROI or rules of engagement
you know one of the things I think I
even tweeted it at one point was saying
look some of the actions that we're
seeing from the police would have been
illegal or heavily frowned upon when I
was in Iraq right the rules of
engagement and one of the situations
that I always caveat say look there's
incredible complexity and in today's
environment being a police officer is
almost an impossible task right because
literally everyone's filming you all the
time everyone's agitating like there's
just so many issues that go on but I
think it was in Louisville the cops were
shot at so you can imagine you're police
officer somebody shoots at you and the
way that I've heard the story and kind
of what I've read is they basically
turned and they shot back it just
happened to be with a group of
protesters there somebody gets shot and
killed now was that the guy who shot
them was it somebody else that there's a
bunch of kind of unknowns and so it's
less about that specific instance as
much as if you or I were in Iraq or
Afghanistan and we turned a shot yeah
well if we turned and shot into a group
of unarmed people and ended up killing
somebody there's a lot of questions
going on and you know in today's day and
age there's actually probably a lot of
pressure because there's just a
different rules of engagement there
right yeah I mean there's a whole host
of different incidents we could go over
and bring up we're you know we've seen
on video police you know shooting people
in the back as they're trying to run
away and it's like oh my god if I did
that in Iraq I'd be court-martialed
you're not allowed to do that this is
crazy and I'm not a law enforcement
expert but I think we have created quite
a quagmire in this country we have these
long-standing issues regarding police
brutality but it's not just about
policing it's about the entire legal
structure and how it functions in the
court system
things that you know should have been
fixed a long time ago and you know these
institutions whether it's the police or
the military I think there's a tendency
to try to hold everything together with
duct tape and you know 550 cord rather
than you know bring forth real policy
measures real legislation and
you know fix the problem yeah and so at
least then to this question of there's a
structure legally that exists right you
and I as much as we would want to change
or improve or whatever it's just that's
the environment that we're currently in
that's the legal structure that exists
and so when soldiers get told to deploy
domestically like the 82nd airborne did
you describe a situation where they're
literally sitting there talking about
the constitutional rights and what's
legal what's not legal you know a lot of
people would just say hey look maybe we
don't want our soldiers focused on that
and they should just always you know be
put in situations where they know what
they're being asked to do is legal but
you know good on them I guess for kind
of critically thinking about it how do
you think about lawful orders unlawful
orders and where if at all we ever see
soldiers who basically say look I'm not
going to do that right I'm actually
going to put my gun down because I don't
agree with the orders that were
receiving like any kind of insight
around that well I'm quite thankful that
I was never asked to do anything
unlawful or illegal during my time in
uniform however I think when it comes to
this issue I mean the you know the
conversation comes out of the Nuremberg
trials of course and you know is it okay
to say hey I was just following orders
and you know the conclusion was that no
that's not that is that's not a lawful
protection you can't put civilians in a
ditch and machine-gunned them and say I
was just following orders that's not
okay so I think it's really important
for our soldiers to be informed and
educated about the laws of land warfare
the Geneva Convention and UCMJ and you
know we we submit ourselves to these
institutions the military in this case
but it's not okay to you know just plug
into the matrix and disconnect and you
know give yourself you know give
yourself permission to do whatever
whatever you know your peers are doing
maybe it's not even in water it's just
like hey everyone else is doing it I'm
going to do it
so it's not okay to defer like that and
just turn off your brain yeah you know
we have to we are thinking human beings
and when soldiers are asked to do
something unlawful and illegal it's
their duty to refuse and I you know I'm
thankful that those soldiers that those
82nd soldiers were thinking about these
things again I wish that they had never
been placed in that position to begin
with and that's a that's a political
matter but I think that yet it's
absolutely important that our troops
think about these new subjects yeah I
mean I remember having conversations
with guys in Iraq about like like what
is the most likely scenario in which
soldiers would be aware enough and feel
strongly enough to kind of step down
right and it was always things on
domestic soil like it's so much more
clear-cut when it's on US soil versus
you know in the middle of a war zone
somebody shooting at you like obviously
that there's a lot of chaos there but
but the domestic soil stuff is much more
clear-cut at least in my opinion yeah
and most soldiers want nothing to do
with any sort of like domestic
deployment you know it's just not their
thing yeah that makes sense and so I
guess the other question then here is
we've seen in other countries and this
is something in the United States that
previously has been kind of
intellectually we haven't even had to
think about this because we're so far
from it but we have seen in other
countries things where you get
separation from the military and the
political structure right where either
the politicians want to do something
that looks closer to dictatorships and
the military disagrees and what sort of
strong order sometimes even vice versa
right where actually the military wants
to kind of take legal control and the
politicians want to stay with some sort
of more democratic process like how does
that play out in today's society and is
that something that you think kind of
soldiers are even aware of the
historical precedence that's been set in
other countries and some of the
importance there I mean I don't know how
aware the average soldier is of some of
those things you know like I was having
a conversation with him with a former
French Foreign Legion
air about the Algeria campaign and how
they that they were gonna launch a coup
in Paris because they weren't happy with
what's going on that's back in what the
weight fifties but anyway I mean I think
this last week we did see some of those
things coming to the forefront some very
interesting ways
you saw general Milley the chairman of
the Joint Chiefs wrote a memo reminding
soldiers about their obligation to the
US Constitution which was very peculiar
to say the least and then you had that
uh that phone call where the Secretary
of Defense mark Esper was telling the
governor's that they need to get in
there and dominate a battle space and it
was so upsetting to so many people to
hear the Secretary of Defense talk about
American cities like that and and I
agree with the criticisms but I think at
the same time we have to look at that
comment in context now based on what we
know President Trump was threatening to
deploy active-duty soldiers into
American cities and Mark Esper was
trying to convince the states to call up
more National Guard and quell those
riots so that the active-duty military
was not called up so I mean a very poor
choice of words that he was using but I
think I think I don't know for a fact I
think I know what he was trying to do
there that he was trying to prevent that
the actual military from being deployed
so yeah I do you think you're seeing
some very interesting things happening
with both the civilian leadership and
both active and retired generals in some
ways you could argue trying to sabotage
the White House's policy yeah I mean
look I having a fret conversation with a
friend recently and we started going
through it it was actor general mattis's
letter right and we started to look
through if you go all the way back to I
think it was a navy commander who around
the coronavirus stuff basically kind of
broke command it seems like and end up
being reprimanded for it and ultimately
stripped of control the ship if you look
at you know the situation with kind of
was it tear gas was it not tear gas to
go take a photo in front of the church
if you look at the letter from the Joint
Chiefs or general mattis
you start to get into this weird world
where like the military operates in a
very structured kind of top-down
leadership driven environment I think
the general population knows that but
like doesn't understand it as well if
you've never served in the military and
for those that understand the importance
of some of these things like these were
pretty big inflection points in my
opinion of like people stepping out of
what is normal behavior in order to
either voice an opinion you know I mean
literally to write a memo is a pretty
big deal be based on who it came from
what it said who it was written to like
those things just seemed abnormal yes
what we've seen over the last 20 years
even while we're a country that's
engaged in multiple Wars yeah yeah
absolutely I think you're right and I
would argue that what you're seeing is
the individual leaders trying to rush in
and fill a leadership void and perhaps
even a morality void that exists and as
you as you point out soldiers follow
orders they exist in this rigid
hierarchy this chain of command and you
tell them you know this is why the
America what's the military look you
tell the Marines go take that hill go
take that city they do it like not a lot
of BS they just go and do it you know
unlike many other branches of our
government that can't get anything done
you know you sent in the 82nd airborne
or the Marines they'll get it done but
when you have a confused state when
you're getting conflicting orders and
what we saw this last week with the 82nd
is a perfect example it's a case study
that'll make a great thesis paper you
know or someone's PhD dissertation who's
who's in charge what's going on where
orders coming from how are they being
received and when soldiers are in that
kind of confused State they're gonna
start freelancing and they're gonna
start figuring out what the mission is
for themselves because they have to I'll
give you the another interesting example
of what happened in the last week when
these guys got down to Fort Belvoir they
drew ammunition for their weapons both
lethal and non-lethal they were supposed
to go out with non-lethal
had they been called out an informal
decision was made that each soldier
would carry a magazine of five
six in their back pocket with ten rounds
10 live rounds in the magazine in their
back pocket why because you're receiving
obtuse orders that don't make any sense
and as a squad leader or a platoon
sergeant you will never leave your
soldiers out there hanging and without
any means to defend themselves you'll
never do that because it's morally and
ethically wrong right because that's
your job as a leader is to take care of
those boys now I and again I do not
agree with these sorts of deployments I
don't think that it should have happened
in the first place but when you have
soldiers in a very confused environment
and it's not clear what's expected of
them I they're gonna start coming up
with their own mission yeah and this is
actually one of the things that kind of
blends into I think a lot of the police
critiques as well which is we have to
remember that the United States has been
engaged in war in Iraq and Afghanistan
for almost twenty years now
right and we have trained a lot of
people to be soldiers to go fight a war
this is you know the Train that you
receive has some overlap when we're at
peace time or at wartime but world war
time you know as you describe kinds of
Special Forces training these were
people who had just come from combat who
are here to train you to make sure you
survive and thrive in the environments
they just came from and so what ends up
happening is in my opinion you almost
get soldiers who they're used to going
out on missions right or they're being
prepped for missions in a combat zone
the idea of going anywhere without live
rounds it is so foreign to them right
that they say hey well what is the one
1% chance that something really really
negative could happen here on the
streets of America we better be prepared
right and that's where you get something
like okay let's bring some live rounds
in our magazine same thing happens on
the police forces I think where we
started to see this militarization of
the police and a buddy man who's a cop
said look I went to Iraq I'm on the
police force now he goes I have an MRAP
he's like literally our police force has
a mind resistant vehicle that like we
can stand out of a gun turf there's no
gun up there but literally there is a
gun turret that I can stand at if he
goes you tell me how many people can
in kind of switch context like that even
though they're still carrying a gun and
now it's a protected serve a mission
versus more of a have an offensive you
know combat oriented mission yeah and it
gets even more convoluted than that
because we train soldiers for war but
then we've deployed them to
counterinsurgency missions in Syria Iraq
and Afghanistan where their role is like
somewhere between being a soldier and a
police officer but you're absolutely
right that you know we trained these
guys their experiences they've had in
the Middle East dealing with insurgents
and terrorists and then there's suddenly
having to flip the switch and act in a
completely different frame of mind in a
completely different context when their
entire frame of reference is war and now
you're asking them to become riot
control cops it's just another reason
why that's such a dangerous situation to
be in and some people have not you know
I actually took some criticism from
South Korean leftists for saying this
but there's the gwanju uprising in the
1980s in South Korea there's a horrible
what happened there but the point I was
trying to make was that the South Korean
government deployed the military and
South Korean special forces to deal with
the student protesters and one of my
sources told me that the special forces
soldiers were told that these people are
North Korean communists infiltrators you
cannot tell Special Forces soldiers
something like that and then send them
in to put down student protesters it's
just a disaster and look you know
without kind of getting into the
political ideology and all the nuance
because frankly no one's gonna be able
to solve that problem is that kind of
like there are some parallels or
commonalities is what we just saw right
if you went to ten people on the street
and said was it auntie fun not auntie
foe was it peaceful protesters was it
rioters and looters right like all of
this terminology that gets kind of
thrown around in the political sphere
doesn't really matter because it's just
words at that point when it gets
actually implemented on the ground
though the difference between hey we are
going to kind of preside over and
protect the community during a peaceful
protest for
there is an T foe which is supposedly
now a domestic terrorist organization
you get into this whole world you're
like wait a second like those are two
very different situations and it's all
based on how you verbally describe what
the environment you're going into right
yeah absolutely I think that you can go
into it and have it feeling like hey
these are Americans we need to treat
them with dignity and respect but then
your squad leader gets hit in the face
with a brick and like it's game on you
know there's a there's an incident again
problem mostly forgotten to history in
1994 there were these prisons down in
Panama where there were Cuban exile that
had a big uprising there and the US
military played a role and putting them
down there is a platoon of American
military police and somebody decided
that the gravel in these camps the
gravel would be like fist sized rocks
and these guys were MPs armed with like
batons and riot shields and they were
like modern-day Spartans like forming a
phallus and they got that they got
hammered hammered so then that night
that MPs went in with some guys from 2nd
Ranger Battalion and delivered an unholy
ass whippin on those prisoners with like
ax handles and baseball bats I mean it's
just another example of why you don't
use these types of soldiers for this
type of mission it just doesn't work
yeah it's pretty crazy well what's your
thoughts on what the average citizen can
do that's probably the number one
question that I've got from people as
they've kind of see all of this unfold
there's the health crisis the economic
crisis think of the social unrest and
they're sitting there and they're trying
to balance kind of two worldviews one is
like the world is you know collapsing
and everything is horrible and it's only
gonna get worse the other is hey we live
in the safest most prosperous time in
human history and like yeah things may
be a little uncertain here there but
like generally we're trending in the
right direction
how do you kind of balance those two
scenarios and then like if you're the
average citizen who doesn't have the
military training and things like that
like what's your kind of advice to them
I guess yeah this is a you know an age
of uncertainty and irrationality and
that paradox absolutely exists and I
think solving it is kind of like the
conundrum of like the modern West
from world like where where do we fit in
where do we exist what is our identity
and I don't know that I can solve that
for anyone what happened what I would
just offer is this is that you know pick
one or two things that you can speak to
from your experience from your knowledge
you know if you're a nurse you can speak
to health care if you're a firefighter
or a police officer you'd speak to being
a first responder or you can pick a few
things and really study them in depth
and then push for meaningful change in
those one or two things I think that
because of social media and you know the
24-hour news cycle our attention is
pulled in a million different directions
you know in my case I know I know the
military and I know this sort sort of
stuff and I had the context so I write
works of journalism that hopefully
enlightens people or illuminates them to
certain things that are happening but
and I would encourage others to look at
it that way think about what you know
and then what you can do and focus on
you know one or two things rather than
spreading yourself too thin you know in
this time we're in right now I think
this is a great time to push for
programmatic policy reforms one of the
big big problems we have in you know
modern-day America is we have protest
movements
it could be Occupy Wall Street it could
be the current movement were you if you
want to call it BLM or you want to call
it something else but there's a lot of
anger and frustration in regards to
police brutality and you know it has to
coalesce around policy reforms otherwise
it just becomes this sort of outpouring
of emotion that doesn't go anywhere so
that that would be you know if I got the
you know play king for a day that would
be my suggestion to people yeah it's one
of these things and I forget who I saw
it online I might actually even been you
somebody just said look asking for
justice sounds great it's really hard to
measure success against that right
because justice means something
different to everybody on you so they're
called glittering generalities peace
justice truth everybody wants those
everybody but it's you ask them hey well
how do you feel about those guys over
there or how do you feel about those
you know BLM protesters and the amount
of venom that comes out of their mouth
you know it's not really so associated
with the peace and love that they were
saying two seconds ago yeah but it feels
like the protesters I saw a proposal
recently I actually forget what they
called it but notice like there's eight
key points around
I was called police reform right and it
was everything from kind of
demilitarizing to some stuff with the
unions or whatever but it was the first
time I had seen like okay here's eight
bullet points like literally it's good
it's in a bullet point you know format
and maybe you can't get them to kind of
negotiate all eight of them right you
can't get the police to agree to certain
things whatever but like at least you
got a starting point now right half of
it it's good exactly here's our demand
list right and and if you kind of go
through the game theory like your demand
list better be pretty aggressive because
you know you're not gonna get a hundred
percent of it like put some things on
there you're willing to give up I was
really interesting from that perspective
last thing I wanna talk to you about is
uh kind of the current state of media
right so you've had some of the most
extreme experiences as a journalist
right you've literally gone into combat
zones I kind of done all these different
things but you don't work at the New
York Times you don't work at you know
the Washington Post talked to me a
little bit just how you think of your
job and how it's evolved over time and
the tools and kind of where you think
media in general is going outside of
those large organizations well I've had
somewhat of a regular experience to say
the least you know I kind of you know
for better or worse I mean I pull
vaulted over some of the things that
other journalists have to do I started
off my my career in that world working
for a small company that I helped found
and startup and now I work for another
company a larger company but I'm you
know I'm just one cog in the wheel of
course covering veterans issues I've
covered very some very niche issues and
I've had the luxury of kind of picking
my own assignments and to a large extent
executing them the way that I wanted to
so I've been very fortunate very lucky
in so many ways
I do have critiques and criticisms of
the media and I mean
we have to define what we mean by media
this is media you know reruns of friends
is media but we're probably talking more
about the press right
specifically the press and the biggest
problem I think it has right now I mean
is that everyone's kind of chasing web
traffic and this was something that
Andrew yang brought up and actually
pretty prominently it was pretty funny
to see during his campaign is that you
know everyone's chasing cliques and it's
all about cliques and you know and
people also complain about the media but
this is the flip side now I would flip
that around on them a little bit oh yeah
a lot of the media is not good and it's
actively detrimental but why do you
click on it like why do you watch it but
why are you consuming that media like if
it's true that you just want facts why
don't you just read AP and Reuters and
stick to the facts but you don't the
data it shows something different the
data shows that people go after that
content that is emotionally engaging and
gets them angry and gets people riled up
so there's a certain amount of
individual responsibility on the other
hand is that as consumers of media
readers of the news consumers of news
media you know we have an obligation to
ourselves and our family and our friends
to you know sort the garbage out and
focus on you know good reporting so I
tell people that they get mad at me when
I say that because it kind of interrupts
you know the the the idea that you know
America would be like a Norman Rockwell
painting if not for the media but there
are problems you know the press has
problems they you know what I was on
referencing before that you know they're
chasing click-through traffic it's one
of the bigger problems the 24-hour news
cycle is one of the bigger problems the
constant churn of content that you know
everyone has to get it out there and you
have to get it first and you have to be
writing every day
and when you write every day you're
really not an expert on anything because
you're just spread too thin so there's a
lot of problems I don't know how we come
out of it I mean
I don't know if you know the the boomers
out there they're already lost like they
have not been able to adapt to this
media environment at all my generation
is struggling I think maybe it's gonna
be a younger generation that's kind of
known to inoculate themselves to it like
they're gonna I think they're gonna grow
up with a more natural filter of like
yeah that's nonsense and just like
they're they're gonna be the ones who
are not going to click on it because
they're gonna grow up with a different
frame of reference and kind of sorting
out the garbage but that's also
something we could probably teach media
literacy in our schools and you know how
to verify like is this story true is it
false should I pay attention to this
should I not pay attention to this you
know I can't tell you how many times a
day I have people you know trying to get
me like why don't you cover this story
why don't you cover that story and it's
like hey this is like a no-name
alternative news website there's no
byline on it there's no this is the most
important thing you learn in college
check the source citations where are
they if they're not there why is that
just as very basic media literacy those
are things we should teach the teenagers
in in high schools around the country
and that would do wonders for us you
know just nationally yeah the one that
gets me is excited with you that like
the media literacy is much easier to
implement when it comes to if you see
like a website article right for all the
things you just announced but the one
that blows my mind and I don't know what
the solution is right so it kind of
sucks that like you understand the
problem but don't have any proposal
first solution is the social media
content right and the thing that I saw
recently that just absolutely caught me
off guard was I'm sure you saw this
picture of the White House with the
lights turned off right and there was a
bunch of people sharing this photo and
they're saying you know hey when when
the protester showed up for demands yeah
the president was turned off the lights
I went in the bunker right or you know
whatever it was and like it fit
perfectly into the narrative right I'm
so for like I saw that probably for
three days and thought that was an
actual picture and then after three days
of seeing it I saw somebody posted an
article and was like hey that pictures
fake right not fake in terms of it it's
a manipulative
it's just from a different period of
time yeah and I was sitting there like
wow for somebody who like I actually
think about this stuff pretty regularly
whatever I didn't even think twice about
like whatever because literally there
was a media article that said hey the
lights went out he went in the bunker or
whatever and you just naturally make
them remember the pictures of the
Mexican immigrants and the detention
facility that were spread around social
media and it turned out is from the
Obama administration another great
example right and so it's like you kind
of get into this world of even the
people who think about it all day still
get tricked yeah for human and so you
almost gotta understand hey we're not
gonna solve it a hundred percent but how
do we move it forward and in a major
leap so that we can actually start to
get people good information so they can
make good decisions and really stamp out
some of the divisive miss but again to
your point the reason why the media
creates a lot of that content is because
it works right it's doing and in the
media I mean the press also provides a
certain amount of fact-checking there is
some self correction so like yeah like
you know three days later the other side
of the story comes out and you saw in
the mainstream media like no actually
that's false um okay you know like you
said people are human they make mistakes
I've made mistakes it happens but it can
be incredibly dangerous I mean imagine a
mistake that you know could incite a
riot that could incite an attack that
could incite an act of war it's
incredibly dangerous incredibly scary to
think about and like you I don't
necessarily know what the answer is
maybe that's one of those things that
like AI will solve for us as time goes
on because it will the fact-checking
will happen so quickly that it will be
exposed but I I mean as long as we're
human beings involved in you know
writing and producing news there are
gonna be mistakes in it you know from
time to time by my favorite example that
I saw of kind of the way that a
situation can be written at from two
different perspectives is there was a I
want to say slate but don't hold me to
the exact publication but I think it was
slate they wrote an article
police erupt in violence over the
weekend was the title of the article and
basically they they were saying look
everyone's writing you know saying the
looters and them and the protesters and
the violence it kind of that that was a
narrative and they basically flipped
around and said well hold on a second
here like here's a bunch of videos of
the police like swinging a baton an
unarmed guy right and the point was kind
of made just by using that headline and
what you start to get into is like look
we need critical thinking and individual
responsibility because ultimately like
you're responsible for the information
you consume and also how you then
process that information right and
that's that's the crux of the problem is
that there's more information available
to every single human being on the
planet than ever before in history but
we have not yet developed on an
individual personal level the ability to
process and analyze all that information
you know and even as you know I was
sitting here talking about a I know the
military blah blah blah I'm an expert
but this last week there's more
information coming at me than I could
possibly process and it was overwhelming
and I wasn't able to accomplish
everything I had hoped to accomplish so
if in my little niche my little corner
of the world I'm overwhelmed then you
can imagine how bad that must be for
other people out there who know nothing
about these subjects you know and I
might know something about the military
but you know like you know we started
talking about finance I asked you
earlier if you ask me about quantitative
easing easing I'm lost I have no idea
what I'm talking about so you know when
it comes to the you know finding out
some is lost as anyone else in this
country yeah well and as I responded to
even the finance people couldn't
describe it right now because it's so
chaotic listen Jack I could sit and talk
to you literally forever Oh what what I
finished up each episode with same two
questions first being what is the most
important book that you've ever read Wow
you know I I was thinking about that
also you know book that really had an
impact on me as a person and even in the
military if you were to ask me both in
the military in journalism in my entire
life
the one that really affected me the most
is the divide itself by RD Laing who is
a Scottish psychologist and he was very
very interesting in in the sense that
here's a real criticism of psychiatry
not not necessarily that he was anti
psychiatry but he criticized it this is
back in the 60s and 70s where there
electro shocking mental patients all the
time I mean it was really true Kony and
stuff
he believes in breaking down the
barriers between the doctor and the
patient and he even did this experiment
for several years where he lived in like
a group home with schizophrenic and but
he lived there with them and lived with
them and they ate together and they did
everything together and you'd say you
know the patient's help me and I help
them and he was against this idea that
um that anyone who experiences the world
differently can be categorized as insane
you didn't believe that and he believed
that a society has messed up as ours has
no business whatsoever in calling
someone else insane now we're the world
world we're a society we wage wars we
murder people we wage these horrible
horrendous atrocities and then we're
gonna point our finger at somebody else
and say hey that person is insane
because they experience the world
differently than I do so and so RD Laing
kind of his work I think
influenced me and how I relate to other
people in my job and in my life and that
I just don't believe in these artificial
separations and these silos not you know
and I'm not saying I'm always good at
this but as far as breaking down some of
those barriers that exist between people
and different Stratus of our society
that I think it's important to go and
experience what they experience there's
a really famous story about our dealing
and it appears in the movie they
recently made about him I where there's
a mental institution there's this
teenage girl and she hadn't talked in
years
she has sat there and sell his padded
cell rocking back and forth so you know
Ronnie Lange goes any visits and he sees
this he goes into the cell and he sits
down next to her and he starts rocking
back and forth next to her and after
about two hours she starts talking to
him and he's just he's an eccentric but
brilliant a singular person singular
human being one of those people that the
world wasn't and isn't quite ready yet
for I mean that that's an incredible
perspective of the world right it
reminds me actually of um Kanye West
says uh you know show me a genius who's
not crazy of this play on words of like
it you know you're you're crazy if
you're not successful but if you're
successful oh yeah then you're the
genius right and and it sounds like this
guy really really understood some of
those nuances
yeah the Leonardo da Vinci's the nikola
tesla's of the world you know the world
just isn't ready for them yeah it's
pretty crazy alright so from a
hard-hitting question to a much more fun
one aliens believer or non-believer I
think they're probably out there
somewhere I think et is out there I
don't think that we have any contact
with them I don't think that you know
all about UFOs I don't think they're
from outer space or anything like that
but yeah I think they're out there
somewhere I'm on some world for us to
discover one day what is the logic
behind believing that they're out there
I agree with you but what's kind of how
do you get to that
I think there's just so many world so
many galaxies so many planets that by
chance there's gonna be one that is you
know close enough to a Sun but not so
far away that life can begin developing
there and you know it seems like we're
finding some evidence of that but
they're really the real you know
conundrum there is because of the the
great time spans involved will
civilization evolve on two separate
planets in the universe simultaneously
but they're able to discover each other
rather than like one going extinct you
know so we these civilizations exist at
different times you know we might
explore space and find entire planets
that are irradiated because they wipe
themselves out with new chemo Wars or
something so that's another interesting
question yeah I couldn't agree more the
the spectrum of time is the most
underrated aspect of this whole thing
you know as soon as it's easy to forget
like hey there world's been around for
like you know billions of years later
yeah alright our lives seem not so
important in the grand scheme of things
all of us yeah yeah maybe et burned
himself out they burned out their
civilization a billion years ago I mean
or maybe we will a billion years before
some other planet evolves who knows
somebody forget who came on and their
question to me was uh not do aliens
exist or not but do we want to discover
them or do we want them to discover us
right right we probably want to do the
discovery awesome jackal listen I
appreciate you taking the time to do
this you're doing some excellent work
and obviously your perspective is is one
that's very rare and unique which I
think it's important in today's times so
please keep up the good work where can
we send people you you want to send them
to to go check out the book do you want
to send them somewhere else would be the
best place for people to go check you
out oh geez
well yeah people are more interested in
my own experiences and anecdotes I wrote
a memoir called Murphy's Law that you
can find on the Amazon or bookstores
anywhere covers my time in the military
and my time as a journalist as well and
I also run a weekly live stream and
podcast and we interview members of the
special
operations community also people from
the CIA we do it live we take newer
questions talk all about their own
experiences so you know it's not just
about me if you really want to find out
more about me and go check out the book
but you know we really enjoy me and my
co-host Dave Park really enjoy bringing
on these veterans and these uh you know
retired members of the intelligence
community and hearing about their
experiences you know all the way back to
the Vietnam War
you just had I think I saw somebody who
came out special-operations and then
became a CIA like kind of field officer
right yeah yeah my friend Jeff Butler he
was a Navy SEAL officer and then he
became a CIA ops officer and was
deployed to Afghanistan so yeah he's a
he's a really interesting guy it's a
it's a pretty crazy life to live but but
it's full of some good times and good
stories so people should have to go
check it out we'll link to it in the
description all right thank you I
appreciate it Anthony all right sounds
good Jack we'll do this again soon yes
sounds great